okay and we are live how's everybody
doing tonight
welcome to a round table with the stream
team and we are going to be talking
again to another content creator this
evening and it is one of our one of our
co-host today so what we're gonna be
doing is what what I explained last week
is that we're gonna take the first
couple of weeks so you all can know who
we are and this week we have old-school
style here today's today as our guest
slash co-hosts if you will so old-school
style welcome to welcome to the
roundtable well appreciate you having me
here thank you very much for you know
taking your taking your time to spend
you know your weeks sitting here
chatting with with us and with you know
the other content creators that we will
be having come in in in the future weeks
so so old-school just tell us how you
you know started wines become a constant
creator well I would say from the
streaming side a we used to play the
game that kind of got me streaming was
actually pub key because there was a
bunch of us that were playing this over
and over again and I was watching twitch
mixer wasn't quite there yet and I'm
like you know what this looks like it
would be fun you know let's let's get a
bunch of us on and just stream away and
have a good time and it just kind of
snowballed from there so so you started
end up streaming on on Twitch and kind
of just was it kind of pulled you in and
intrigue to you that you wanted to you
know continue to to keep going with it
it did I I like the sense of building
the community and it was being an adult
and having to work God knows how many
hours it's nice to be able to get on a
stream and you get to talk and converse
gate conversate and and be with
like-minded gamers that that kind of
have those
many times but want to have that
interaction and and it literally just
build from there I went from twitch to
mixer to D live to YouTube and I pretty
much stream anywhere at this point so it
doesn't matter which platform is just as
long as you're streaming then you're
you're enjoying you got it yeah
excellent now we also have NJ as a boss
here this evening he is you know doing
doing his college think you know the the
best snapchat person in the business if
you will so how are you doing
you know here's five-time and I assume
right oh all right well we're gonna try
to figure out a way to get you and get
you some more game time ha ha ha
excellent excellent so while we are all
here as as you'll remember we had old
school he is uh he is the man of the man
of the hour if you will so uh old school
now you as you were stating you you've
been you know streaming on multiple
multiple platforms so which would you
say is probably your favorite one if I
had to pick one I'd probably say mixer
tends to be the better out of the group
it just gives more options to creators
to to interact with with their audience
are you talking about the low latency or
which particularly what part of that
kind of makes it more intriguing I would
say when you're when you want to stream
with someone you want to co stream you
can actually have using the NFL red zone
term the quad box up you can have up to
four people on the same screen so it's
almost as if you're in the room with
these same people as far as when you're
watching from the outside and and that's
what I really like about mixer right do
they end up when they
were they implemented that did that give
now there is one this is gonna sound a
little awkward but when you let's say
I'm watching you and MJ and l-boogie all
you guys are streaming at once does it
is it considered one view to all
three-year streams do you know it is it
is so because believe it or not
twitch actually has implemented
something very similar to that like they
like the quad zones like you're talking
about but they actually the only view
you get is the main box the main person
you're looking at which is yeah this is
kind of interesting kind of weird
well you'll depending on which which
stream where you go to see so say you
jumped in my stream and an MJ and
yourself and now are all in there so if
you go to my stream you were only going
to see my chat but you can click on each
window to jump back and forth between
the chats and not have to pull up for
different browsers and bada theater now
that's real nice now what now you
started you said with do you start
streaming pubs you guys soon yep that
was uh that was the game we were
streaming there were a couple couple of
folks I played with which is the
wandering Dutch or Goosen he's on
twitter and fatal enigma and then we had
whoever else was joining us and yeah we
just we all streamed and we just kept
playing pub G till we got the chicken
dinner how often did you guys and do you
end up doing like the twos threes
Tuesday five which we we always we
always tried to do with the four players
and honestly we were terrible at first
but then we got consistent you know we
were playing on xbox and of course
everybody had been playing it well
before on PC so yeah we uh we had our
butts handed to us quite often but you
know we had that first win you get you
get hooked so yeah now did you end up
did you end up trying to do other games
other like what battle royal games I can
take the word battle royal yeah we um
fatal and I did a lot of
black ops when it came out but it just
got harder and harder with the work
schedule and have you and some that's
when I started kind of joined more on my
own going out and just kind of grab them
whatever game I felt like playing and
stream it yeah you didn't get any of
that hell no and you know is I can't
knock the game the game the game is the
game it just is what it is but it's just
it's too it's too cartoony for me even
even I have my limitations I like a
little bit more realism to my battle
royale did you end up ever playing like
you've tried fortnight I assume I guess
everyone has tried fortnight at some
point
truth be told no nope oh no I had it
loaded on my xbox forever and I had
never played the game really have did
now for me personally like I ended up
playing fortnight the original like I'm
talking about the the PvE one and I
thought it was fantastic I thought was a
lot of fun I thought was great I really
enjoyed you know playing with my friends
for a PvE you know the PvE track if you
will I thought that was fantastic and
great so once they brought out the
Battle Royale
I did give it a try once and I was like
I'm like I don't know if I kind of like
this and then I tried it again I was
like no this isn't my cup of tea no no
no that installed and I actually never
touched it again but I feel like that is
more cartoony than then pub then oh I'm
sorry now pop G on Call of Duty yeah
yeah I agree
Carla Carla duty has more of the it's I
don't know if it's cartoony but I
consider it more of like a bright
graphics but it's still it's still a
graphic game it's more of an adult
scheme unless you have chat on then it's
an
different story and I I agree with you
when fortnight the original game first
was released where it was you had to
build everything and then you fought
these hordes of whatever that was
attacking you I thought it was a good
concept which is why I downloaded the
game but then after that they just
walked away from it court with the
Battle Royale when when I still play
call of duty all the time I used to love
it I throw the fantastic game I thought
like I used to end up playing it believe
it or not because during the time like
coal duty modern warfare 2 came out that
was around the same time that where the
Warcraft came out it came it was there
on 2003 2004 and I actually used call of
duty to help like improve my twitch
skills because I felt like B you needed
to have those that like fast reflexes
back then but now like the with the wall
running and the sliding I'm just like I
guess I guess you kind of relate to this
I was just like I'm too old for this I
just this is not this isn't my cup of
tea
yeah I didn't even get involved in that
one the most recent one that came out
the was a black ops for its its back as
much as they can to the original so
there's no jet packs there's none of
that crazy stuff but it's still they'd
still call a duty its it's a twitch
shooter so yeah
it's you gotta have the reflexes for it
I got I gotta ask did you at least play
titanfall I played a little bit of it um
never been a huge mech guy but a game
played well well yeah I agree
I did I did i I never played titan full
one but I play titanfall too because
it's I felt tubes for the PC and I felt
like there was something about when you
called your Mac down you're your Titan
and just like dropped it and you slid in
there and you were fighting on your
Titan and you're like yeah there was
something amazing about it but then once
again you had that like the wall running
and everything I was just once once you
weren't in the Mac it wasn't it wasn't
the combat for me no I would definitely
agree with you on that one it's uh I
liked it I
I played well the campaign was good I
just I multiplayer
no so after you after you started
streaming and those types of games did
you this is when did you end up
realizing that you really really love
the horror games oh man I've always
loved her games I will say I was hooked
back when Resident Evil came out and I'm
talking the first one because I'm that
old
it's about it well yeah we bought we
bought it on a whim it was myself and
two of my friends and we're like what
the heck is this like you know let's
just buy it and I've been on that train
ever since for the most part I play
whatever horror game I can get my hands
off did you ever did you ever play this
on the hill series love the Silent Hill
series there's been other ones that I've
played and I want to say the real
oddball one which actually kind of was
like Silent Hill which I say is clock
tower god I love that game
yeah I never I never ended up planning
for this or a PlayStation 2 yes yeah I
recall I never played clock tower but I
remember my brother and I'm playing
Silent Hill and the first time now I
don't know what we were thinking but we
ended up playing Silent Hill in the dark
and we got super freaked out the first
time we saw the pyramid heads once they
started walking in there and dragging
the sword and I was just like okay I'm
done yeah
lights are on I'm done yeah that's game
over it's like alright bye
yeah I'm gonna go so would you say that
like you're the first the first Resident
Evil game like you kind of just like you
think you were saying kind of like suck
you in pulled you in you like enjoyed it
and loved it and then like you know that
that was like your genre of choice to
stream or do you have do you have one
that's a that you know is your choice as
far as streaming goes I play whatever I
feel like playing I've never
I've never kind of went with the term
variety streamer because it's not like I
stream everything but I I I stick to
what I'm in the mood to like I recently
have been playing controls a live stream
control before that I was doing
graveyard keeper which is a fetch quest
system that is just beyond boring but
you know I enjoyed it it was a good time
so I really can't say this is the vein
that I'm in mm-hmm how often do you end
up getting time to just a stream
recently who not a lot but I try to
schedule it out I'm gonna be trying to
schedule it out going for it then I'm
gonna at least get 2 hours to 3 hours a
week where I can kind of jump on and
just hang out with everybody play
whatever is on the schedule for me
whatever I feel like playing and just
kind of go from there
I have a quick question so out of all
the games that you play to which game do
you think you've streamed the most oh I
would probably say pub G because we we
played that day in and day out from the
time it released on Xbox all the lays up
until its official release when it
wasn't in beta and that was that was
quite a bit how many chicken dinners do
you have couldn't tell you look at me
tell you no I I haven't opened the game
in so long but maybe they sell out of
them more than more than a KFC more than
a KFC box
I would I would probably say I could
open I could open a chain of KFC's are
you gonna sell out of them like Popeyes
no no man but I'll be okay if they want
to fight through the drive-through
window so like when you when you start
streaming what what type of and you we
know that you you're doing more than
streaming now which I what I want to
talk to you know the YouTube Tech Talk
that you're you know you want to do but
what where did you end up like wanting
to go like where did you end up starting
to stream
you would like to just get like one pcs
just with the camera you start streaming
or was it more of a gradual or where
where was it with you where where did
you start where like what type of
equipment did you get and kind of like
builds forth like what you have now when
when I started streaming I looked for
the best economical way to do it so I
actually used my cell phone as a camera
because there's an app you can use to
connect it to a computer that's I used a
laptop that was an i3 processor oh wow
and my xbox and that was that was
basically it
and I started on twitch you did now when
you when you started doing it that way
because that that is the the the super
like just super cheap conservative way
did you still have to get a capture card
at that point no because what I did was
use the Xbox app and use the laptop to
screen capture the app oh that's it
that's true
that was the once again I went
economical because I wasn't sure if it's
something I really wanted to get into
yeah and you can absolutely go down a
rabbit hole with streaming and all the
equipment so I'm like let me see if it's
something that I can really get into and
then we'll go from there
right well that's you you ended up kind
of like going forward like from from
that to where you are now because I know
now you have a vastly more elaborate
stream set up Danna yeah so so we're
like where where did you start evolving
it's where it is now the first thing I
got into was a capture because I wanted
to be able to get better video quality
so my initial purchase was an HD 60
which was the external rights were no
pro kado and then I went from there to
an internal card when I built my new
setup but that's that's initially where
I went and then I went with Logitech
c920 to camera yeah so those were the
true upgrades so I ended up I ended up
starting also with the with the with the
HD 60 external and I found that it had
decent amount of latency did you did you
end up noticing that when you first set
it up I found the software that comes
with that is not good it caused a lot of
problems and you're right a lot of
latency yeah it didn't it didn't marry
up well with with what I wanted to do it
was it was incredibly slow yeah yeah I
felt like that and then I I I started
with a like a very chancy camera and
then I ended up I did the same thing you
did I just went for the it was a called
the Logitech X X xx xx xx the 920 the
nice one and that camera it was just it
is beautiful it's a good it's a good
choice and you know from my opinion so
what do you what did you end up doing
with your with your audio cuz I know you
have a kind of a an interesting audio
setup to write when I first started with
the audio I just use whatever mic now I
have a full array microphone and
what-have-you but I use for my audio
itself I use a program called voice
meter banana which is a free mixing
board so it allows me to bring in a
couple of microphones bring in three
other audio sources so I can have my
chat goin I can have my discord chat
goin and I can have another chat going
but I can separate it so it doesn't go
to the stream and I but I can continue
to talk to it it's it's probably one of
the better programs that's out there
so what was it what was that program
again just uh so few people are
listening voice meter banana whose inner
banana yep and meter spelled m ee ter
it's a it's a free download from their
website they do ask for donations so if
you can donate to them absolutely but
you'll you'll find that if you use that
and once you get familiar with it you'll
never go back to anything else
interesting so I I've noticed that a lot
of people they end up like PC players
mostly they want to end up using they
want to end up streaming capturing their
voices in addition to like being on
discord and they don't want the people
in discord to here feel like you know
for it to go into their stream because
you know some people that want their
privacy and it sounds like this is
something that could end up splitting
that information so want to go to the
headset and and it wouldn't end up going
to your stream it's exactly what it'll
do you know can you can chat it up what
you discord or if you get big enough and
you want to do a subscriber only discord
you can chat specifically with them and
it won't go to the stream interesting
that's nice that's really nice we're
affiliated with twitch I was affiliated
with twitch are you still fill it
I have rescinded my affiliation with
twitch because they the thing with
twitches is once you get into the
affiliate program with them those are
you that are affiliated know that your
content is locked down for at least 24
hours so you can only live stream to
twitch at that time and anything you
create can't be moved anyplace else you
can't post it on YouTube and nothing
like that and I really prefer to multi
street so I sent them an email saying
hey I'm gonna I'm gonna back out of the
program and they sent it back saying you
could to go I said a thanks yeah sorry
well so are you streaming on mixer now
or you full-time mixer are you
everything I am everything
literally add some days I'm mixer and
twitch some days I'm just twitch some
days I'm YouTube and mixer sometimes I'm
D live and mixer it really depends on no
no reason why you have that back content
split I find that how can I put this
there's certain times of the day when
you stream on certain platforms that
your content isn't really the priority
to whatever that platform is we all know
twitch tends to be heavily favored
towards particular types of streams so
if you're gonna be when those streams
are on the it's hard to get any push in
there
so I find being able to direct my
audience where I'm at gives me more of
an opportunity to see them and hang out
with them because that we all have
different streamers we like to watch I
do I watch Pete from work I'm like hey
Pete I'm here so if there's someone else
streaming during that time and I have a
couple of other people that do it's hard
for me to watch everybody so I try not
to give that too I try not to put that
burden on other people I try to move
around with them
well now from from what I like because I
always catch you usually when you know
lunchtime around for me when you're when
you're streaming and you know you most
of the time I usually get you when
you're either on on Twitch or mixer do
you find that you were your your fan
base if you will like jumps from each
platform depending upon where you are or
do you see mostly like let's say they
got I'll only see you in like one place
or two and like some people will only
see you in another place or another like
your your community will almost won't
intermingle because you're on so many
different platforms you'd be surprised
there there's folks that that will go
for a mix other twitch and twitch -
mixer there's folks that will follow
from D live to mixer and I see more
mixer folks
on a platform like D live than I do
anything else and then YouTube is a
whole separate community which they'll
show up when they show up and and that's
okay but a lot of high-end streamers
have left a mixer to go to D live so
that's why there's more mixer folks that
will come to the streams over they have
a twitch why are people just just to you
know enlighten all of us a little bit
why do you think that people are leaving
make sure to go to D live instead of
staying there well D live is a you can
still get their version of partnered an
affiliate over there but as a content
creator on D live you instantly start
making money it's cryptocurrency so
there's a whole logistics with that but
they their currency is what they use the
bitcoins of that yep something on that
idea
it's called Li no L Ino so I think more
content creators went over to there
because the the standards to make
partner on mixer or affiliate on twitch
it can be hard it can be a bit of a
grind where you can walk in the D live
and start making revenue off your
content right away and that's what some
people want that it's kind of a very
much a definite draw to want people to
like kind of have them start streaming
there because I was I was in a very very
interesting situation when I was not not
partnered but you know the dream but
when I started to stream i streamed for
about a year and and then maybe about a
couple of months after that they
announced that they were starting the
affiliate program and I already had all
the qualifications so it was almost like
boom you're good and you know you
instantly became affiliated and you got
all those perks and you know a family
and friends that instantly started
subbing to me
and then it was a very very fluid change
for me and that it was perfect for me
but someone that's kind of new that's a
real draw because I feel like most
people that are starting streaming they
they were in it for for the money
because I feel like most of the people
see how many people are you know subbing
and how many people are doing their
thing on Twitch and they're like oh I'm
there for the money so how can I make
money quick and then they realize that
it's not just as easy as just starting
like you need to have you know like
we've been going through you know you
have to have that certain streaming
software and you have to have like know
what you're doing with all your
equipment and then at that point you you
end up you know having to make the
criteria to get affiliate and and most
people they don't they don't want to do
that they don't want to produce the
grind they just want to kind of get and
go you know what I mean oh yeah yeah and
it's and there's something to be said
for when you grind something out and you
get to that level but yeah it's a lot of
folks are just like hey how how can I
make that ninja money how can I get that
doctor disrespect money and and they
shoot for the quickest way there and
honestly those folks were grinding away
quite a bit before they got to where
they were how many parents do you think
after they saw that one kid one that
huge fortnight tournament one Mountain
bought kids gaming PCs so they can
stream to be like that I would say the
the parents that are those highly
competitive parents that when it all
costs I would definitely say they they
definitely went out and purchased
something but most probably said hey you
got you pull it you get you ps4 and and
where I used to do tech support for an
internet provider taking phone calls
saying hey my internet doesn't work
you'd be amazed how many calls I would
get from parents saying my child's
complaining that the ps4 picture quality
is poor and he's trying to string for it
that could no it's crazy how many people
I would get I'm surprised that you know
ah I think I feel like the streaming
content creators I'm talking twit like
the bakelite what I like to call the big
boys mixer into it like I'm surprised
that they don't have in place things
that's and even YouTube things in place
that say you cannot live stream unless
you are XH they get it see I never I
never saw that
I only saw in the terms and services
that you have to be at least 16 years
old to be streaming right but and see
that's the thing is they're to have to
go out and enforce that would be almost
impossible it's like trying to block
certain people from going on the
internet you just you can't do it
remotely it has to be done in the home
and and streaming can be a rough world
so I hope parents are kind of watching
what they're doing their kids are doing
but yeah there's no way to stop it
gotcha gotcha do you do you think that
the the evolution of streaming is now
kind of falling onto those young kids or
do you think that the older generation
just like us is kind of like the the
people the hub that are holding it all
together I think it's gonna be as with
any media I think it's a constant
evolving I think it's going to be up to
us that have been doing it for a while
to kind of let the younger folks know
hey this is the path you want to walk
you know make your own robe but kind of
stay within these margins so mcc's
but if streaming is uh it's in my
opinion it's gonna be there it's gonna
be what TV used to be back and back in
the days when TV was like the thing haha
how are your co-workers and friends or
were they supportive once you first
start streaming
I know no one's ever supportive no did
you like tell them about it
of course I did and they always girly
really yeah they have bail thought I'm
crazy they're like why you wasting time
there were some that were out there that
were like yeah absolutely you know do
you do you but most people are like
you'll never do anything you'll never
get anywhere and it's like I'm not doing
this to to get somewhere I'll be doing
nothing Lundy yep yeah it's I'm doing it
because I want to do it cuz isn't it
should be fun yes so that's a sentence
so that actually brings up a very good
question that I was actually bringing up
I was gonna bring up next um so why why
did you end up then becoming a streamer
just because you wanted to have the fun
you just want to have the fun of
streaming community is there like a you
know a sole reason for it yeah that's
that's honestly why I still do it til
today it's it's for that it's for the
community it's for the interaction I'm a
very realistic person that I am NOT
gonna make millions or thousands even
doing something like this but it's more
I hey let's do it for the games and for
the enjoyment and not for a dollar
amount
do you like the people that you know
coming to your to your streams and stuff
like that that they're they're mostly
then like you know people that you've
met through throughout the communities
throughout you know networking events
and things like that
absolutely absolutely a majority of the
people that are actually if not all of
them that are in my streams are people
that I've met streaming or are the
streams that I've gone to and made
connections with people now have you
gone to like a bunch of the gaming
conventions yet to network yet or I have
not all my networking is done the
streaming it's everybody I talked to and
then getting in people's dis cords and
on Twitter I have not been to any of the
events who
who's your favorite streamer right now
is this where I'm supposed to say you no
no you don't have to say me should I say
no but like we all have our favorite
streamers that we you know what I like
to call our our go-to guys that you know
that are always there that I can always
go and I know that they're there to
communicate like for me I know that if
Danna was on I will always be in his
channel because I've ever since I met
him at PAX East like we've had a really
really good connection and bond to the
point where like we almost talked daily
and you know we bounce ideas off each
other and things like that which is
great for for me being a new streamer
but at the same time like this guy you
know he doesn't need to take his time
out to to help me or communicate with me
but I feel like right now like we've
become more friends and you know those
are those people that like the the
larger partner streamer is I you know
for someone like myself is kind of like
a you know almost like an untouchable
kind of like a celebrity in in the the
internet world so I'm sorry so go ahead
so what's your what's your who's your
person who's your tree there's there's
two guys that I consistently try to
catch when I can and and I'm in their
discord and I and I chatted up with them
one gentleman's name is Rico and he's on
Twitch and the other one is Joe Vitt
ACCA's he's on Twitch as well both very
relatable guys very cool there's times
where I've had problems with my setup or
I'm having issues with something I'm
like hey guys I'm having a problem with
this okay kind of like you give give me
some give me some ideas on how to get
this fix and and and it's been vice
versa they're like hey are you
experiencing this we were running into
this might yeah this and then we've
talked about games and what-have-you so
they're the those two guys right there
it's in my opinion top tier straight-up
guys that I'll catch whenever I can you
feel like it almost is like like a
trickle-down effect like these
guys kind of helped you with your
situation and for instance when you have
someone like Lorde Cognito who has a
problem you know you feel that you know
you're more inclined to be able to help
him because you know they helped you I
you know cogsa man let me just get yes I
agree I was just using as an example
right but it's good because we were we
were going back and forth and DMS today
with with his ongoing issue and and I
reached out to him because it's like you
know what I've been there I know some
people won't say anything I know some
people like hey here's an issue you
figure it out and we were kind of
throwing ideas back and forth to try to
figure out where his problem was but I I
will help people not because they've
helped me but because I've been there
and I'm much right to help them solve
their problem so they can get better do
you feel like it's almost like a really
good support system I do
yeah I did this there's there's and I
have you and I have gone over stuff
that's been issues in the past and it's
it's nice to be able to have people that
are there or have been there and like
hey what do you think yeah for instance
you know last week you you were saying
that you felt that your sound firfer our
stream was was not up to your standards
and your method of fixing it it's
something that I would have never
thought I would have ended up spending
you know you know couple like you know
30 40 bucks started buying like sound
dampening it's just stuff and you ended
up fixing it with what uh what did you
say a blanket in a clothes rack blanket
a clothes rack it's you know and I don't
hear I don't hear any reverb any echo
anything like that and it's you know a
cheap thing that that is awesome you
know I think that's I think that's all
that's great well I I'm gonna I can't
say I took the I created that idea I
actually borrowed kind of that concept
from Linus tech tips who did a room with
a room full of bean bags to dampen sound
I'm like I
use a blanket okay I'm Judith so I
really think so are you affiliated with
mixer like you're partnered with them or
anything
nope I'm not I'm not uh you can't tie me
down I'm not tied to anybody so it's
your Mexican ninja you know as as we've
discussed in the past if someone knocks
on my door with a bag of money I'm gonna
take that bag of money
hi mama didn't raise no fool but for the
time being I'm very happy just kind of
being able to go wherever I want to go
by the way I just envisioned something a
logo of someone stealing a bag of money
that that's like a shirt Network that
what that would that's something we got
that we got to get on that um some side
bar I just thought of right now how so
because you you are very very similar to
a lot of the other members of stream
team your your your very work driven all
right um how how has you know your want
to become a content creator affected you
know the people in your home it hasn't
been easy mostly because it's the wife
and I work really whacked out schedules
so I try to to design my times with all
my with all my content that it doesn't
interfere with my time with her yeah
because ultimately I need her support to
continue to do what I do
yeah yeah it's and and her knowing how
passionate you are for these things is
she very supportive not supportive you
answer these questions obviously oh no
no I'm I'm an open book
I'm blood-type I don't know that I know
it's on a card somewhere
she's supportive of everything I do she
there's things will come up and I'd be
like hey I want to do I'm thinking of
doing this and then she she's the the
grounded one where she'll be like is is
is this gonna run you this much money is
it gonna run you this much time how much
time do you have in your life and then
it's like okay let me evaluate that with
those metrics and go from there she's
she's unbelievable she's absolutely the
biggest supporter I got that's great so
that's amazing that's great to hear
that's you know you kind of need that
that that pushing force behind you oh
yeah yeah and and you need you know when
you're doing this essentially you're
working out of your house like you have
to treat your your content creation as a
business yeah so to have that support in
your home helps tremendously I got I got
just a couple more questions before I
want to ask you about your new endeavor
but are you are you coming to PAX East
next year are you gonna be coming to
hang out with all of us if I can get a
date I will get the time off and I will
definitely be there yeah cuz last year
was tough last year was tough I just I
couldn't get the time yeah I know cuz
last year all of us we were hanging out
and we were like oh I was old school
gonna make it is you're not gonna make
it and then you know unfortunately you
know you had you know your personal
obligations that came up that you know
preventing you from doing it but we
definitely we definitely to get together
and hang out with you and and you know
just do some stuff Oh a cog in the chat
I owe you you know right I probably do
but I'm pretty sure drinks are gonna be
on you cog Oh what about
III do you think you're gonna go next
year um possibly possibly that that's a
that's a huge financial trip people and
then it may not be happening for much
longer
it's I've done one so I'm good
alright I I understand that to me that
was the Superbowl beginning so yeah
right I did my one
previous company I worked for I used to
get past this for free so well I had to
pay for it was a hotel and and the
flight out there now it's a little
different so what which is the oh my god
I'm blanking on the name which is the
germany-based one-game job yeah from you
know it's it's Monday you know um so
James Caan from everything that I've
heard you know that is going to evolve
into the new III which is really really
intriguing and really fun to know and to
hear and to see that that's what we're
gonna start you know what's gonna start
turning into that like I would like it
to go there I think Gamescom is is a
better place to do it
do you think I'm sorry do you think
there's more developers on the Europe
side then there is the US side yes I
think there's a ton more over in that
area than there are over here yes um
cogs in China he just said he's he got I
got you brother when your drinks let's
go all right I'm there so I try to do I
tried to do it with the kognito accent
but clearly I I am terrible at it so the
the next thing you plan on on doing is
you know something that you brought up a
week or two ago was your your tech
streams so your tap well is it more of a
stream or just a youtube channel it is
just a YouTube channel for now and I
used that caveat because it always
evolves into something else
but it's just gonna be YouTube with
videos and and I've always been a
hardware guy so you know I like my toys
I like my text so I said hey you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna share this with
folks so you're you're kind of going out
there buying and buying or getting your
own tech in some way shape or form and
then do it's pretty much just doing
reviews on them and you know cutting up
the videos and adding some some void
some voice - and things and stuff like
that oh yeah yeah it's like the the last
video I just put up we
I had B role in it I did voiceover in it
I had live shots in it so yeah that's
like I've I will say anything but you
know there's there's a phone that comes
out on Friday that I may or may not have
yeah so so I'm gonna I'm gonna be doing
a fair amount on that mostly I'm gonna
try to get info up on the Apple arcade
because that that kind of piqued my
interest I have another question
joy so once you got your PC was it
pre-built there did you build it
yourself I built it myself there's
there's there's no reason to buy a
pre-built PC unless you have no desire
or no skill yep do build your own do you
feel that at the because of your
technology type background you're able
to do it and you felt like you know
comfortable and cheaper and and all of
that well I don't know if it was cheaper
but as far as having the skill that I
had which is going back to my days as a
wee tad and taking apart my handheld
electronics with a screwdriver yeah yeah
I would say that that probably helped a
lot yeah I've always felt like if you if
you have a regular PC that you want to
build out it's the preferred way to do
it if you wanted to build your own
machine because it seems to be cheaper
in the long run as for like laptops I've
always felt like why would you want to
try to build something like that because
you know what's not gonna fit in the
case it's almost so once what's that
happens it's like okay we're gonna do uh
we're gonna try to fix this up and we're
gonna it's like I just I'm just getting
on without thinking about it so yeah
laptops or laptops or by him and upgrade
them yeah I would never build a laptop
from scratch but yeah as far as desktops
go II think it's God
lot easier on the software side to build
them because you don't have to go
through that whole crazy configuration
but the components are always it's
always been plug and play as long as you
understand the concept of something
fitting this square peg in the square
hole you can build a pretty easy I have
a question what do you love to have
Linus's job I would love to get the
stuff Linus gets yes I would
there is no way I would want to run
Linus
Media Group that is yeah hey awesome I
can it's just too much how oft how often
does he put out content like this is
pretty frequently yeah Wow yeah um Jase
two cents and a gamer's nexus those guys
are unbelievable for tech stuff yeah I
feel like like like Eric's like those
guys like I I full full disclosure I
didn't really know them that much until
they actually came out to ILP I was
podcast Sundays at eleven so uh they
pluck the shameless plug they when
talking when cog and all those guys when
they were talking to axe I was like wow
this guy's pretty genuine this guy's
pretty cool let me go check out his
channel and then went on his channel I
looked at it and I was like wow like
this guy he's got some crazy good
content and then I realized that he's
got this like team behind him that ends
up like doing all the building and all
that up and I was just like wow I'm like
this is very very impressive so I
thought I thought that those guys are
like the sheer quantity of content
excuse me that they're putting out is
it's crazy
now old school do you have a plan to put
that YouTube content or you kind of just
plant it by ear or right now the goal is
one a week yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna
get a video out either Sundays or
Mondays every week until I can start to
free up more and more
or time and then maybe get to it being a
little bit more expansive yeah
now the the present video that you just
put out the one for the lovely or
Michael microphone why why did you end
up changing over from you know the
standard you know like a lot of people
they interview Singh the Yeti mics or
the razor Mike's too to be a lavalier
mic well the the Yeti mic for the most
part sat on my desk I didn't have a
microphone arm nothing like that I
looked at getting one but then it's like
it's another piece of gear off my desk
and I do the recording for the videos
from my phone I not spending money on it
on a DSLR camera none of that stuff so
being able to have a mic go right to the
phone just immediately improve sound
quality and then I'm like you know what
I could use this on the computer so now
I don't have to have the mic on the desk
so if I'm typing people don't hear me
racket in a way on my mechanical
keyboard because the sound vibrates
through to the getting yeah can't hear
it is there is there one piece of tech
that you can't live without normally I'd
say my phone but yeah it's my phone yeah
it's if it's in my phone it gets done if
it's not in my phone it doesn't get that
that's that's my rule of thumb at this
point which was oh if I lose my phone
nothing gets done which which one you
have the note 9 is it this is big it's
not the big one it's it's it's a good
sized phone it's it's a 6.2 screen I I
had an s10 plus but I gave that to the
wife cuz she really liked the phone so
I'm like here you take this one I'll
just go I'll go grab a note I'll be fine
yeah do you you uh what's your service
plan I am on t-mobile and it is
unlimited
oh yeah but I'm on Wi-Fi everywhere so
are you gonna get that new iPhone
maybe that could be a thing I like I
ended up I'm on Verizon right now
because I got my Google peso and the
more and more I think about it the more
and more I'm thinking about going at
Google fee I was I was on Xfinity mobile
for a little bit and t-mobile made it
really really really nice to come back
they're like please come back old school
come come back to to the Durr said I I
got I got three phones for the price of
two plus they've paid off my old ones oh
wow that's really nice yeah I'm like
yeah I mean what about Google Stadium
how do you think that's gonna go I think
it's gonna have its market as much as
its it's getting beat up I think there's
gonna be a need for it it's it's gonna
be it's gonna be neat it's not gonna be
for everybody but I think it'll be okay
did you hear for you a pre-order it you
get destiny two free game oh wow
free game give you a free game did comes
with destiny to accept the thing isn't
about like two weeks destiny two is
going to be for free dare exactly yes oh
yeah i i i i can't see by I can't see
buying into it right now I any one of
these new streaming services I would
hold off yeah that's I think the guys
are talking about that yesterday to the
they were talking about was it EA and
what was the other streaming platform
that they were talk about origin yeah it
was urgent I'm not I'm not that's that -
yeah that's yeah yeah I don't remember
but I was trying to think to myself and
be like which of these companies is
going to is gonna make it which one is
not and it's like there's gonna be too
many there's going to be too many
platforms and people are gonna get
spread out and what's going to come down
to is going to be the people that have
the best marketing team to be able to
retain people because I think that ei I
don't think they're gonna I don't think
they're gonna be able to hold any though
people unless they're just throwing
around money and the other the other the
other group I can't believe I'm blanking
on the other one I felt the same way
no I wasn't PlayStation now I'm
surprised that still up never hear
anything about that you know I think
that PlayStation now they're probably
they're probably saying I don't wanna I
don't want to mess with us right now we
have to deal with other types of you
know streaming service stuff and I think
I think that the the big three are more
concerned now with like with like not
streaming but like like Google stadia I
guess they're considered streaming
services those services than anything
else right now
so that's why I feel like they they
pulled the like mixer pulled that ninja
move ninja moves get it the ninja move
and that was kind of just like alright
this is going to be us trying to do our
marketing ploy for a mixer for the next
year so we get all this crap with speedy
it like down and held out with Amazon
and all that stuff and then we'll come
back to it that's all the more I'm like
listening to and thinking about that's
how I kind of I kind of feel I feel it's
uh I feel it's going to become a it's a
big big group of courses in a race and
it at some point there's gonna be three
that are going to or three that are
gonna get in front right I know all
these other ones it's just going to kind
of bundle up with them it's whoever's in
my opinion whoever has the most reliable
service is going to win the games the
games are great but if if the service is
terrible people aren't going to take it
right it's not yeah I really I really
have been feeling that Nintendo is going
to hold their own they they are
that they have been around since almost
day one for them to not make it it
doesn't make sense and with their leader
being Bowser who is the best name for a
video game company is like I think he's
going to they'll be fine
but the others I'm not sure PlayStation
they have this if they have the backing
of the people and of the the exclusives
and if Microsoft keeps their game pass
come in along and hold in their own then
everything will be fine and I think that
the they actually pulled the numbers
four gears and I think that gears this
gears five is actually the lowest
revenue gears game and yes and people
are wondering if it's because they went
to game pass with it yeah of course they
did you had you had them talking that
they had three million people playing
the game that they only had one hundred
was it like 1.2 or less than a million
dollars of copy sold
yeah math math doesn't add up so that
means two-thirds of your people are on
game Pass
yeah which means they Microsoft needs to
really take a step back now and
reevaluate like which games they're
gonna be putting in game pass on day one
because you know you can end up sticking
a game like see if thieves in there
which everyone knew was dicey and they
knew they weren't going to make money on
it but they knew that they were gonna
have publicity with game paths and then
it came and held their own so I this is
what I think Microsoft really wants I
think they they're very gung-ho with
getting into the streaming service with
game past and everything they want the
mobile market that's what they want you
look at a company like $0.10 they made
three billion dollars yeah in revenue
last year just and all they do is mobile
games right so it put in a game like
gears 5 and game pass and taking the hit
on that in sales but if they're able to
drive that mobile business it ain't
gonna matter
they won't even blink an eye make sure
it makes you wonder if the thoughts of
was it the Apple Apple arcade so the
same wonder if how that's gonna affect
people because Apple arcade let me let
me rephrase that
Apple products are pretty much in
everybody's hands if you like it or not
you're getting one I'm an Android I'm an
Android user and I have Apple products
too not by choice but because I'm given
to like work gives them demands like hey
you need to use these so even if I don't
want to use an Apple products
I literally have one of my hands so the
Apple arcade is really going to affect
where people are thinking or gonna be
doing I looked at the games and they're
launching with a hundred games which do
you know do you know some of the high
end titles off the top of your head or
now I I don't either scrolling through
them and and they have some they have a
couple of big game players making games
for it but it's it's $4.99 a month
everything everything is now going
streaming service of some sort pay like
a pays monthly service I mean world
Warcraft started it and everyone's now
just following suit because they see the
the benefits of it yeah well and and
with with the apple arcade it's
literally an app done you paid through
iTunes and it's just recurring and it's
gonna something like that is absolutely
like a Netflix people will never
remember that until they realize oh hey
past years yeah yeah it's kind of like a
gym membership you know you go and then
you forget to cancel it I mean you
forget to go um so so uh MJ do you have
any questions before we get the final
question to answered all mine so the
final question if you could live in one
video game or fantasy universe what
would it be
funny we had this conversation the other
night at work you did you did
we literally this exact conversation
someone someone brought it up and I'm
like you know what I think I'd live in
Silent Hill everyone's like real what
that I am I I'm speechless right now why
why would you pick that out of any
universe well at least I know what I'm
dealing with I think I know all the
crazy players that live there so I'm
kind of okay being there that is such a
left-field like I would never ever
imagine that to be your location of
choice for the forever oh yeah yeah I
would be very comfortable with that very
very interesting um so why does it why
don't you tell everybody you know where
to find you what's going like you know
what's new in the pipe let's go what's
happening with yourself alright well you
can definitely find me over on the
Twitter's that's a old school style
there you can catch me on Mixer old
school style there twitch it's
old-school style 70 and the youtube
channel which is schools Tech Talk you
can catch me there that about covers all
the places that I need to be though
those are all those all the places
that's that's what that's what we're
gonna cover for now okay that's we're
gonna cover for now yeah no one's get no
one's got pen and paper right now no but
hopefully people are listening to us on
iTunes so that they're you know pausing
and writing all these down so so MJ
we're we're about you you can find me on
twitter at bay TMJ and then you can find
me on Twitch MJ as a boss
excellent excellent so I'm I'm just
gonna give a little shout-out to to Our
Lady of the table l-boogie Oh - oh eight
she is going through some stuff right
now and she's gonna be here travelling
across the country and
you know we loved her dearly and you
know safe travels we can't wait to get
her back on the on the cast with us so
she should be you know hopefully back
within the next week or two so hopefully
she's there she's on mixer primarily and
on Twitter so if you want to go catch
her she is l-boogie o 208 so go check
that out
I am so now though that's a sin a ly do
and I am on Twitter on Twitch usually
from 7:00 to 10:00 Monday to Friday I am
usually there even before this cast
starts and usually I take 30 minutes to
get myself ready and then come back on
here so thank you all for hanging out
tonight for the e for the chat monkey
punch how do you do I'm bud thanks for
stopping in now just a reminder we have
Lords of gaming net please go check out
those amazing articles we have there we
all write something in some way shape or
form
MJ puts a couple of different types of
articles for games coming out for
PlayStation and Xbox and things like
that me Ubisoft type products and
hopefully we can kind of squeeze an
article or two out of old school so I
can get some fun form for him in there
so he can get all ready to come to pax
with us and I was per usual iron Lords
podcast is on at on Sundays it is
football season so it is 11 o'clock
Eastern Standard Time and our podcast
year round table with the stream team is
going to be coming up on iTunes and
Spotify and I think Google podcasts on
Thursday if you want to catch early
edition by all means right here on the
iron Lords podcast YouTube channel thank
you very much everybody
our Twitter I told almost forgot our
Twitter for round table
the stream team is a table stream on
Twitter please by all means go on there
you'll see when we finally get the stuff
out on to the other platforms who our
next guest is going to be and what you
know when we're gonna be going live and
our next guest with some luck is going
to be MJ's boss if by all means you have
questions you want to email him if you
want us to ask I should say please email
round table stream team at gmail.com and
we will try to go through and get some
of those emails and questions asked so
thank you very much and remember
everyone dream big and keep gaming have
a fantastic week everybody bye